je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous une
cordiale bienvenue à bergheim pour cette
inauguration de notre troisième édition
du slowup alsace
ce taux est du cru prestation tout à
fait exceptionnel il ya rencontre un
succès inespéré puisque l'an dernier
choix qu'on a les plus de 29 mille
participants sur un parcours bien que
dizaine de lits de m c'est terrible ici
sur le piémont
les deux vignobles alsaciens entre le
haut-rhin et le bas-rhin et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui encore ça va être un
magnifique succès c'est ça vient aussi
la rencontre avec la politique
départementale en matière d'utilisation
de moyens de déplacement doux notamment
de notre politique de puisqu'il ya
certainement parmi les nuisances euse
dans d'autres shale et que nous ajustons
avec nos collègues du bas rhin
dans un endroit de symboles et puisqu'il
nous sommes à la limite administrative
entre l'eau un barrage militaire des
bêtises administratives et ça monte
aussi la coopération qui peut exister
entre les deux départements entre des
clubs de thé de communes du rhin et bas
rhin du bas rhin pour accueillir des
touristes
rappelons quand même que par née des
succès de l'autre région un peu d'eau du
département
c'est l'attractivité touristique c'est
une réussite le tout à fait
exceptionnelle puisque nous y
rencontrons ces dernières années des
taux de fréquentation de plus en plus
aidé d'une seule évidemment heureux pour
l'activité économique dans nos ateliers
nos restaurateurs de théâtre